You probably know what it feels like when a conversation just clicks. You and the person you're talking to understand each other. They're not just listening to you. They're hearing what you're saying. You leave the conversation feeling good. Maybe you sparked a new friendship or deepened an old one or figured out how to solve a problem that's been bothering you. Conversational chemistry might seem intangible,
你大概知道当对话一拍即合时是什么感觉。你和你交谈的人互相理解。他们不仅仅是在听你说话。他们是在听懂你所说的话。谈话结束后，你会感觉很好。也许你擦出了新友谊的火花，加深了旧友谊，或者想出了如何解决一直困扰你的问题。对话的化学反应可能看起来无形，
something that just happens when the circumstances are right. But psychologists using new research tools and methods are beginning to figure out what makes some conversations work while others fall flat. And their insights can help people improve their conversation skills, strengthen their relationships, and even disagree in more productive ways. So what makes conversations click? Why are some people so much better at verbal communication than others? What role does listening play in conversation? and how can you learn to listen better? Why is it important to think about your goals in a conversation
似乎只是在环境合适时自然发生。但心理学家们正利用新的研究工具和方法，开始弄清楚为什么有些对话能顺利进行，而另一些却反应冷淡。他们的见解可以帮助人们提高对话技巧、加强人际关系，甚至以更富有成效的方式产生分歧。那么，是什么让对话一拍即合？为什么有些人比其他人更擅长口头沟通？倾听在对话中扮演什么角色？以及你如何能学会更好地倾听？为什么在对话中思考你的目标如此重要，
and to consider your partner's conversation goals as well? What's the best way to build rapport with someone you just met? How can you disagree productively without having the conversation spiral into an argument? And what are the most important things you can do to improve your conversation skills? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association,
并且还要考虑你对话伙伴的目标？与刚认识的人建立融洽关系的最好方法是什么？如何在没有让对话演变成争吵的情况下进行富有成效的分歧表达？为了提高你的对话技巧，你可以做的最重要的事情是什么？欢迎收看《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. I have two guests today. First is Dr. Michael Yeomens, an assistant professor of strategy and organizational behavior at Imperial College in London. Dr. Yomans has a PhD in behavioral science from the University of Chicago Booth School of Business and was previously a postdoctoral fellow at the Harvard Business School. His research uses an artificial intelligence management.
它探讨了心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我有两位嘉宾。首先是迈克尔·约曼斯博士（Dr. Michael Yeomens），他是伦敦帝国理工学院战略与组织行为学助理教授。约曼斯博士拥有芝加哥大学布斯商学院的行为科学博士学位，此前曾是哈佛商学院的博士后研究员。他的研究利用了一种名为自然语言处理的人工智能管理
method called natural language processing, to analyze conversations, to understand and improve how people communicate with one another. He's interested in how people make decisions and conversations and how we can make those decisions better. Next is Charles Duhigg, a Pulitzer Prize-winning journalist and author. His new book to be published in February 24 is called Supercommunicators, how to unlock the secret language of connection, and it's all about the science of conversation. Mr. Duhick is written for the New Yorker magazine and the New York Times, among other publications. He is also the author of two bestselling books, The Power of Habit, About Habit Formation, and smarter, faster, better about the science of productivity.
方法来分析对话，以理解和改善人们之间的沟通方式。他感兴趣的是人们如何在对话中做出决策，以及我们如何能做出更好的决策。接下来是查尔斯·杜希格（Charles Duhigg），普利策奖得主记者兼作家。他的新书将于2024年2月出版，书名为《超级沟通者：如何解开连接的秘密语言》（Supercommunicators: How to Unlock the Secret Language of Connection），这本书完全关于对话的科学。杜希格先生曾为《纽约客》杂志和《纽约时报》等出版物撰稿。他还是两本畅销书的作者：关于习惯形成的《习惯的力量》（The Power of Habit），以及关于生产力科学的《更聪明、更快、更好》（Smarter Faster Better）。
Thank you both for joining me today. Thanks for having us. Thanks, Kim. It's a pleasure to be here. We've all met people who seem to be naturally great at conversation. They can connect with anyone. Charles, in your book, you call people like the super communicators, so what are you? Why don't we start there? Who are these super communicators? And do you have any really great examples?
感谢两位今天能来参加我的节目。谢谢邀请我们。谢谢金。很高兴能来到这里。我们都遇到过那些似乎天生就很擅长对话的人。他们能与任何人建立联系。查尔斯，在你的书中，你把这样的人称为超级沟通者，那么你是怎么看的？我们何不从这里开始？谁是这些超级沟通者？你有什么非常好的例子吗？
Yeah. Well, I think actually all of us know super communicators. And oftentimes we are super communicators ourselves. If I was to ask, I'm everyone listening to think of the person that you would call if you were having a bad day, the person you know that would make you just feel better, kind of listen to you exactly the right way. Everyone listening would have someone pop into their mind. And that person for you is a super communicator. They know how to listen. They know how to show their listening. They know how to speak in ways that it's easier for you to listen. And we all have these moments in our own lives when we when we know exactly the right thing to say to a friend to make them feel better. Or we know exactly what to say during a meeting in order to get everyone on board with our idea. It's not a magical
是的。嗯，其实我认为我们所有人都认识超级沟通者。而且通常我们自己也是超级沟通者。如果我请收听节目的每个人都想一个在你过得很糟糕时会打电话给的人，那个你知道能让你感觉好点、以恰到好处的方式倾听你的人。每个收听的人脑海中都会浮现出这样一个人。对你来说，这个人就是超级沟通者。他们知道如何倾听，知道如何表现出他们在倾听，他们知道如何以让你更容易听进去的方式说话。在我们自己的生活中，我们都有这样的时刻，当我们知道该对朋友说些什么来让他们感觉更好时。或者我们知道在会议中该说些什么来让每个人都赞同我们的想法。这不是一种神奇的
power is the thing. It's a set of skills that some people have learned a little bit better that recognize more, but there's skills that all of us can learn, instincts that all of us have, that if we're reminded how to use them, we can communicate with anyone. Now, Mike, you don't use that term in your work, the term super communicators, but do you come across people like this in your studies? And what are they doing that the rest of us aren't? Yeah, Kim, I think it's a great term. I come across some of my studies. And if I'm lucky, I come across a few in my life every once in a while, too. I think Charles describes it really aptly, right?
力量，关键在于。这是一套有些人学得更好一点、能认出更多的技能，但这些技能是我们所有人都能学会的、是我们所有人都有的直觉，只要提醒我们如何使用它们，我们就能与任何人沟通。现在，迈克，你在你的工作中不使用“超级沟通者”这个词，但在你的研究中你遇到过这样的人吗？他们在做什么而我们其余人没有做呢？是的，金，我认为这是一个很棒的词。我在我的研究中遇到过。如果我很幸运，生活中偶尔也会遇到几个。我认为查尔斯对它的描述非常贴切，对吧？
These are people who understand their conversation partner. They understand the goals they want to achieve and what their partner wants to achieve and have the skills, have the adeptness, the quickness and the sensitivity to be able to build a conversation from turn to turn over time so that it actually adds up to something much bigger than that, right? not just exchanging words, but meeting of minds. And I think Charles also makes a really good point about the nature of the relationship, right? Like so often when we are at our conversational best, it's because we're with people we understand well. We know their patterns.
这些人理解他们的对话伙伴。他们理解他们想要达到的目标以及他们的伙伴想要达到的目标，并且拥有技能、熟练度、敏捷性和敏感性，能够在对话中一轮又一轮地建立对话，随着时间的推移，使其最终积累成远比这更宏大的东西，对吧？不仅仅是交换言辞，而是思想的交汇。而且我认为查尔斯关于关系本质的观点也非常深刻，对吧？比如，通常当我们处于最佳对话状态时，是因为我们和我们深入了解的人在一起。我们了解他们的模式。
We know what they're looking for. We maybe share a sense of humor with them. And there's a bit of a filtering at who we end up talking to, right? We tend to seek out the people we've had good experiences with before. but I think we can learn from those situations the kinds of skills and tools that can be useful more broadly. And a lot of what the real super communicators do, the people who are good like this with everybody, is that they understand how to adapt their toolkit to the needs in the context in front of them. One thread that runs through the work that both of you do is the importance of understanding
我们知道他们在寻找什么。我们也许与他们有共同的幽默感。而且我们在最终和谁交谈时有某种过滤机制，对吧？我们倾向于寻找以前有过良好交往经历的人。但我认为我们可以从这些情境中学习那些可以更广泛应用的技能和工具。真正的超级沟通者所做的很多事情——那些对所有人都这么擅长的人——在于他们了解如何调整自己的工具箱，以适应他们面前的需求和语境。贯穿你们两人工作的一个共同主题是理解的重要性，
that there are many different kinds of conversations and conversational goals. Why is it important to understand your own goals and your partner's goals in conversation? Well, in many ways, a conversation is all about the goals, right? We oftentimes enter into a conversation with a specific objective in mind, although we might not be aware of that objective ourselves. And one of the things that I've really loved about doing this research, including Mike's research and many of his colleagues, is that as we learn more about how communication works within our minds, we've learned that there are different kinds of conversations, right? And in particular, it seems like there's sort of three big buckets that we can put a lot of conversations into. There's conversations that are practical, right? I want to decide where we're going to dinner tonight or what we should do about the fact that Jimmy can't get his homework in on time.
即存在许多不同类型的对话和对话目标。为什么在对话中理解你自己的目标和你的伙伴的目标很重要？嗯，在许多方面，对话完全关乎目标，对吧？我们通常带着一个特定的目标进入对话，尽管我们自己可能并没有意识到这个目标。而进行这项研究（包括迈克的研究和他的许多同事的研究）让我真正喜欢的一点是，随着我们对沟通如何在头脑中运作了解更多，我们了解到存在不同类型的对话，对吧？特别是，似乎有三大类我们可以将许多对话归入其中。有实用的对话，对吧？我想决定我们今晚去哪里吃晚饭，或者对于吉米无法按时完成家庭作业这件事我们应该怎么办。
Or I want to talk about, you know, what we should do as we get older. And that's kind of a conversation about, like, what are we really talking about? What do we want to figure out here? But then there's other types of conversations where the goal is not to come up with a plan or to use reason to figure things out. It's just to share with you how I feel. And those are emotional conversations where what we're talking about is, is how do I feel? And then another big bucket are social conversations, discussions where I am sharing who I am from an identity perspective, from a background perspective, based on my experiences, I want to learn who you are,
或者我想讨论，你知道的，随着我们变老我们应该做些什么。这有点像关于“我们到底在谈什么？我们在这里想弄清楚什么？”的对话。但还有其他类型的对话，其目标不是想出计划或使用理性来弄清事情。而只是与你分享我的感受。这些是情感对话，我们谈论的是——我感觉如何。另一个大类别是社交对话，也就是我在其中从身份视角、背景视角、基于我的经历来分享我是谁的讨论，我想了解你是谁，
based on where you come from and what you believe in. And that's really a social conversation, a conversation about who are we. And what's important is that a lot of the research shows if I come into a conversation and I'm talking about emotions, if I come home from work one day and I've had a tough day and I'm telling my wife all about my boss who's a jerk and my coworkers don't appreciate me. And my wife responds with some very good practical advice. Like, why don't you take your boss to lunch and get to know him a little bit better? Even though she's trying to be supportive, even though that's very good advice, it's unlikely I'm going to hear it. We've all been in this situation where I'm having a lot. an emotional conversation and she's having a practical conversation. And as a result, we don't
基于你来自哪里以及你信仰什么。这确实是一个社交对话，一个关于“我们是谁”的对话。重要的是，许多研究表明，如果我带着讨论情绪的目的进入对话，如果我某天工作很累回家，经历艰难的一天，然后把我那混蛋老板和不欣赏我的同事的事情统统告诉我的妻子。而我的妻子用一些非常好的实用建议来回应。比如，为什么不带你的老板去吃午餐，多了解他一点呢？尽管她试图给予支持，尽管那是很好的建议，但我很可能听不进去。我们都曾处于这种情境中，我在进行一场
connect. We don't hear each other. We both walk away a little bit frustrated. So I think one of the big things that I've carried away from reviewing this research is it's important to have the same kind of conversation at the same time. And that means understanding what your own goal is and what other people's goals are in a discussion. So, Mike, does that mean that people need to announce to each other what they want to talk about, what the purpose of the conversation is? Does that make you a better conversationalist? I think a little bit of announcing could be helpful. I also think a little bit of asking could be helpful too, right? There's many parties involved. I mean, we, I think those three categories are, it's a nice way of thinking about the different types of conversations we might
情感对话，而她在进行一场实用对话。结果，我们没有连接。我们没有听到对方。我们双方离开时都有点沮丧。所以我认为从回顾这项研究中我获得的最大收获之一是：在同一时间进行同一种类型的对话是很重要的。这意味着要理解你在讨论中的目标是什么，以及其他人各自的目标是什么。所以，迈克，这是否意味着人们需要向彼此宣布他们想谈论什么、对话的目的是什么？这会让你成为一个更好的对话者吗？我认为进行一点宣布会有所帮助。我也认为进行一点询问也会有所帮助，对吧？有很多参与方。我的意思是，我认为这三个类别，是思考我们可能
hope to achieve. And it's tricky because every conversation could be a mix of a few of them, right? And because every relationship you have is a series of conversations over time, right? So you need to be able to apply, you know, when to apply the skills at the right time. You know, I think some people don't know their own goals. You know, they'll, you know, business scholars will do these studies where people write down their objectives for like, you know, the next year at work or the next five years of their life. And you'd be surprised how often people miss common objectives, even just describing their own goals. And I think the same is true of conversation, right?
希望达到的不同类型对话的一种很好的方式。而且这很棘手，因为每场对话都可能是其中几项的混合，对吧？并且因为你拥有的每一段关系都是随着时间推移的一系列对话，对吧？所以你需要能够在正确的时间应用相应的技能。你知道，我认为有些人并不知道自己的目标。你知道，商业学者会做这样的研究，让人们写下他们未来一年工作或未来五年生活的目标，你会惊讶于人们常常忽略共同的目标，甚至只是描述他们自己的目标时也是如此。我认为对话也是如此，对吧？
Simply listing the goals you might have before a conversation to be clear of what those are, right? maybe even thinking through some of the topics you might cover when you're talking with somebody can only hope, I think, to help you achieve those goals merely by identifying them, but also doing a bit of cognitive offloading in the sense that rather than having to do the cognitive work of trying to think what you're trying to achieve as you're trying to achieve it, by just putting a little bit of preparation in advance, then the actual conversation will flow a lot smoother. And I think the same is also true about preparing to understand your partner. Now, you don't know exactly what their goals are yet either, but you can at least have a plan to learn what
在对话前简单列出你可能拥有的目标，以明确这些目标是什么，对吧？甚至在与某人交谈前思考一下你可能会涵盖的一些话题，我认为仅通过识别这些目标就能帮助你实现它们，同时也能进行一些认知卸载——也就是说，与其在试图实现目标的进程中还要费脑筋去想你想实现什么，不如提前做一点准备，这样实际的对话就会流畅得多。我认为为理解你的搭档做好准备也是同样的道理。现在，你还不知道他们的确切目标是什么，但你至少可以有一个计划去了解
those goals are. I think Mike brings up a really important point here, which is that oftentimes a conversation that we have is not just one conversation, right? We're not just talking about emotions or just talking about social topics. We move from conversation to conversation. And what's important is that our partner is able to recognize as we're moving from topic to topic and is inviting us to join them in a certain kind of conversation. And one of the things that really strikes me is that when we are in those conversations, oftentimes we are announcing our goals. Right. If we're trained to look for it, if someone is obviously emotional, if someone is using emotional words, if someone is saying things like, this is how I feel or I was angry,
这些目标是什么。我认为迈克在这里提出了一个非常重要的点，那就是我们进行的对话通常不仅仅是一场对话，对吧？我们不只是在谈论情感或只谈论社交话题。我们在对话之间穿梭。重要的是，我们的搭档能够在我们从一个话题转换到另一个话题时识别出来，并邀请我们加入他们某种特定类型的对话中。真正让我印象深刻的一件事情是，当我们处于那些对话中时，我们经常在宣布我们的目标。对吧？如果我们受过训练去寻找这些线索，如果某人的情绪显而易见，如果某人使用了情感词汇，如果某人说出诸如“这就是我的感受”或“我很生气”之类的话，
then they're announcing, like, I want to have an emotional conversation. Or if they're saying, look, we got to get down to business, we got to figure out what the budget is for next year. They're announcing that they want to have a practical conversation. And part of it is just training ourselves to listen for that. I'm wondering how you both got interested in this topic. Charles, let's start with you because your profession, as a journalist, involves a particular type of communication.
那么他们就是在宣布，比如，“我想进行一场情感对话”。或者如果他们说，“听着，我们得切入正题了，我们得弄清楚明年的预算是多少。”他们就是在宣布他们想进行一场实用的对话。其中的一部分就是训练我们自己去倾听这些。我很想知道你们两个是如何对这个话题感兴趣的。查尔斯，让我们从你开始，因为你的职业作为一个记者，涉及一种特定类型的沟通。
Can you be a good reporter without knowing some of the basics that you cover in your book and what Dr. Yeoman studies. Well, it's, and I'm really interested to hear Mike's take, I'm answer to this as well. One of the things that I found was happening to me was that I was really good at being an interviewer, right? I could ask questions, but an interview is not a conversation. A conversation is really when both people are participating.
如果不了解你在书中涵盖的一些基础知识以及约曼斯博士研究的内容，你能成为一个优秀的记者吗？嗯，而且我也很想听听迈克对此的看法，我也会回答这个问题。我发现发生在我身上的一件事是，我非常擅长做采访者，对吧？我可以提问，但采访不是对话。对话确实是双方都在参与的时候。
We're both, hopefully, being a little bit vulnerable with each other and reciprocating some of that vulnerability. We're both in the conversation, as opposed to one person, interrogating the other, which is what an interview is often like. And I found that this was a real drawback at work. Like I was a great reporter. But when I was made a manager at the New York Times, I just discovered I was the worst communicator on earth. Like people would come to me with problems and I would try and solve them immediately because I thought that was my job. And they would get upset because they're like quit trying to solve my problem. I just want you to understand how I feel. I was terrible
我们俩，希望都在对彼此展现一些脆弱，并对这种脆弱做出一些回应。我们都在对话中，而不是一个人在审问另一个人，这往往是采访的样子。我发现这在工作中是一个真正的劣势。比如我是一个很棒的记者。但当我被任命为《纽约时报》的经理时，我发现自己简直是世界上最糟糕的沟通者。人们会带着问题来找我，我会试图立即解决它们，因为我以为那是我的工作。而他们会生气的，因为他们觉得“别再试图解决我的问题了。我只是想让你理解我的感受。”我太糟糕了
at this. And so that's when I started thinking to myself. Like, I actually, need to understand how communication works because because we all we have evolved to communicate, right? It's our species like secret superpower. And yet so often we're in conversations where we feel like we don't fully understand what the other person is trying to say and they haven't heard us. And I think that part of the barrier there is just not understanding how communication works. And so I wanted to learn more about it. And Mike, what about you? What made you focus on this professionally. I mean, I think it's an incredible topic for anyone to be studying now. You know, I really, in graduate school in Chicago, I really got excited about decision
在这方面。所以这就是我开始思考的时候。比如，我实际上需要了解沟通是如何运作的，因为我们所有人都进化出了沟通能力，对吧？这是我们物种的秘密超能力。然而，我们常常处于这样的对话中：我们觉得我们并不完全理解对方试图表达什么，而他们也没有听到我们。我认为其中的一部分障碍只是不理解沟通是如何运作的。所以我想要对此了解更多。那么迈克，你呢？是什么让你在专业上专注于此？我的意思是，我认为对于任何人来说，这都是一个令人难以置信的研究课题。你知道，我在芝加哥读研究生时，我对决策
making, right? How it is that people make choices to follow through on their best intentions. And very often that was studied in very simple domains in the sense that, you know, people say they want to retire for, say for retirement, they want to give more to charity, they want to, you know, save on energy usage. We're trying to come up with ways for people to align their behavior with those intentions. And those are relatively easy to measure. I think all the same kinds of mistakes and biases and juristics that plague our decision making in the uncertain world of finance or the uncertain world of dieting and exercise,
真正产生了极大的兴趣，对吧？人们是如何做出选择来践行他们最好的意图的。这往往是在非常简单的领域中进行研究，也就是说，你知道，人们说他们想要为退休储蓄，他们想要更多地捐助慈善事业，他们想要，你知道的，节约能源使用。我们正试图想出方法让人们的行为与这些意图保持一致。这些相对容易衡量。我认为所有那些困扰我们在金融的不确定世界中或在节食和锻炼的不确定世界中的决策的错误、偏见和启发式方法，
health more broadly maybe. I think all of those same problems are also applied to conversations. it's just hard to measure. It's hard to figure out because there's so many different kinds of goals and because the way we talk to one another is structured for humans by evolution, but not structured to be understood by computers. There was just a dart of real understanding of conversation and that kind of decision-making level.
更广泛地说，健康领域也是如此。我认为所有这些相同的问题也适用于对话。只是很难衡量。很难弄清楚，因为有太多不同种类的目标，而且我们彼此交谈的方式是由进化为人类构建的，但并不是为被计算机理解而构建的。在那种决策层面上，真正理解对话的现实非常匮乏。
And so these days, I think with the advent of technology that's allowing us to, for example, the technology that's recording this podcast right now, and we'll give us a transcript after we're done, The ability of tools to capture conversations, but also to enable new kinds of conversations that we never used to have, whether it's with globally distributed work teams or text messaging, you know, with our oldest friends or, you know, networking apps that allow us to connect with people. We might never interact with otherwise, you know, people in online courses, that kind of thing. The ways in which we're recording those conversations and the new conversations that are being enabled by technology means that it seems like such a natural fit for the kinds of empirical tools that psychologists are used to applying to simpler problems. So, Mike, I know that you've done a lot of research around kind of turn taking in conversations and what it sounds like when a conversation is good that people are often interrupting each other and there's callbacks to previous things and they're asking questions. So a conversation like this, if you and I were sitting in a bar with Kim and we were talking as opposed to to, we're in three different cities and we're talking over over the computer, how do you think a conversation would be different?
所以这些日子，我认为随着技术的出现，允许我们——例如，正在录制这个播客的技术，并在我们完成后给我们提供文字记录——工具捕捉对话的能力，以及实现我们以前从未有过的各种新对话的能力，无论是与全球分布的工作团队，还是发短信，你知道，和我们最老的朋友，或者，你知道，允许我们与可能永远不会有其他互动的人建立联系的网络应用，你知道，在线课程中的人，诸如此类。我们记录这些对话的方式以及技术所促成的新对话，意味着这似乎非常适合心理学家习惯于应用于较简单问题的实证工具。所以，迈克，我知道你围绕对话中的轮流发言做过很多研究，听起来当对话很好时，人们经常互相打断，并且对之前的事情有呼应，他们会提问。所以像这样的对话，如果你和我跟金一起坐在酒吧里聊天，而不是我们在三个不同的城市通过电脑交谈，你认为对话会有什么不同？
In person versus online. And, you know, including alcohol in the mix definitely would change the conversation too. Right, right, right. And probably some background noise and verbal or visual cues that were giving. other? Yeah. Well, and hopefully a much more wide open range of topics. I think we have a lot of time to dig in deep into one another and pass the baton a little
面对面与线上。而且，你知道，在其中加入酒精绝对也会改变对话，对吧？对，对，对。可能还有一些背景噪音以及我们给彼此的语言或视觉线索。对方？是的。嗯，而且希望有更广泛的话题范围。我认为我们有充足的时间深入了解彼此，并多传递一下接力棒。
bit more. You know, I've certainly enjoyed getting to know you guys a little bit getting ready for this conversation, but I have so many follow-up questions. I won't bore the audience with, but. I want to ask a question about technology, because Mike, you just raised that. And, you know, we're hearing more and more that younger people. They don't use their phone, for example, for a conversation. They use it to text.
你知道，为这次谈话做准备时，我确实很享受稍微了解你们俩的过程，但我有太多的后续问题。我不会用这些去烦扰观众，但我。我想问一个关于技术的问题，因为迈克你刚提到了这一点。而且，你知道，我们越来越多地听到年轻人。例如，他们不用电话进行对话。他们用短信。
And the kids, I'm using the term loosely, but I'm an old person. So younger people don't even want to have conversations. They'd much rather interact using technology. What will that do to conversation as a skill? One question is whether it substitutes for normal face-to-face conversation that we're used to having or whether it's a compliment, right? In some ways, it could compliment, right? Like, I text my friends to figure out when we're going to meet up and then we meet up and then we can call back to things we've talked about. We can, you know, reference jokes from our meeting and engage in responsive action based on plans we've made.
而孩子们，我松散地使用这个词，但我是一个老年人。所以年轻人甚至不想进行对话。他们宁愿使用技术进行互动。这会对对话作为一项技能产生什么影响？一个问题是，它是否替代了我们习惯的正常面对面对话，或者它是否是一种补充，对吧？在某些方面，它可以是一种补充，对吧？比如，我给朋友发短信弄清楚我们什么时候见面，然后我们见面，然后我们可以回顾我们谈论过的事情。我们可以，你知道的，引用我们见面时的笑话，并根据我们做出的计划进行响应式行动。
All of that makes the connecting of conversations in a relationship much more powerful. But, you know, I think there's good research that others have done and probably know better showing that in some ways it's substituting for the more tangible relationships. in our lives, right? That social media is maybe not quite as social as we'd hope. So that's a tricky business. I don't know much of that research as well. Charles, do you? Well, a little bit. And I think one thing that it's important to remember is I think it's a really good question, right? Because it is such a new form of communication. I have a 12-year-old and a 15-year-old, and I don't know that they ever call their friends, but they're talking to their friends constantly. But the one caution I would offer is, you know, when telephones,
所有这些都使得关系中的对话连接变得更加强大。但是，你知道，我认为其他人做过很好的研究，可能更清楚地表明，在某些方面它正在取代我们生活中更切实的联系，对吧？社交媒体可能没有我们希望的那么社交。所以这是一个棘手的问题。我对那项研究了解得也不多。查尔斯，你呢？嗯，有一点。而且我认为有一件重要的事情要记住，我认为这是一个非常好的问题，对吧？因为它是一种非常新的沟通形式。我有一个12岁和一个15岁的孩子，我不知道他们是否给朋友打过电话，但他们一直在和朋友聊天。但我提出的一个警告是，你知道，当电话
first emerged, there was a flurry of articles claiming that being able to communicate telephonically would destroy our ability to have conversations. Like all these people who don't have to go see each other in person now, they can just call across the city to talk to each other. And of course, all of us have had conversations on the phone that we feel like are as intimate and as personal as any that we've had in real, in face-to-face. In other words, we kind of learn how to use a communication medium in the best way possible. And one of the things that's happening with online right now is that we're learning how to do it, right?
刚出现时，曾有一阵文章声称，能够通过电话沟通将摧毁我们进行对话的能力。就像所有这些现在不用亲自见面的人一样，他们只需跨越整个城市打电话就能互相交谈。当然，我们所有人都曾在电话里进行过对话，我们觉得那些对话和我们在现实中、面对面进行的对话一样亲密、一样个性化。换句话说，我们学会了以尽可能最好的方式使用沟通媒介。而目前线上正在发生的事情之一就是我们正在学习如何做到这一点，对吧？
Like we've been talking to each other face to face for two millennia. And we've been talking on telephones for over 100 years. But when it comes to like sending someone an emoji and like trying to figure out all the hidden meanings that I don't know exist about it, that's a relatively new phenomena. But we will learn and we are learning how to do it. And I think what's important is that at the beginning stages, and there's a lot of really interesting research around this, around how, why people come into conflict online and why they don't. And I think the general policy is, if you over-emphasize what you know you're supposed to do, like if you over-emphasize being polite, if you over-emphasize stating your intention, if you avoid things that are really subtle, like, like, you know, some type of wry comment that you can hear the irony in your mind, but your recipient, reads it on the screen and doesn't understand that you're trying to make a joke. If we fall back
就像我们已经面对面交谈了两千年。我们使用电话也已经有一百多年了。但当涉及到比如给某人发送一个表情符号并试图找出我不知道它存在的隐藏含义时，这是一个相对较新的现象。但我们会学习，并且我们正在学习如何做到这一点。我认为重要的是，在初始阶段（围绕这个有许多非常有趣的研究，关于人们为什么会在网上发生冲突以及为什么不会），一般的原则是：如果你过分强调你知道你被期望做的事情，比如如果你过分强调礼貌，如果你过分强调陈述你的意图，如果你避开那些非常微妙的事情，比如，你知道的，某种你可以从脑海中听到讽刺意味的苦笑，但你的接收者在屏幕上阅读时却不明白你想开玩笑。如果我们退回到
on the basic principles of communication, we tend to do better online. And over time, our kids will learn how to do this better than we do, the same way that we learned how to use telephones better than our great-great grandparents did. Well, let me change gears for a minute and talk about meeting someone for the first time, whether that's a co-worker or a date. I mean, what's the best way to build rapport and connection right out of the gate. There's a lot of great research on this. I'll tell you a little bit about some work I had done, one of my very first papers on conversations,
沟通的基本原则，我们在网上往往会做得更好。随着时间的推移，我们的孩子会学会比我们做得更好，就像我们学会比我们的曾曾祖父母更好地使用电话一样。好吧，让我换个话题谈谈第一次见某人，无论是同事还是约会对象。我的意思是，建立融洽关系和连接的最好方法是什么？关于这一点有很多很棒的研究。我来告诉你一些我做过的工作，关于对话的最早论文之一，
which is studying the kinds of questions you might ask somebody when you get to know them. You know, very often, we started thinking about questions because I think very often the strategy we take and we're trying to meet somebody is to impress them, to give them a lot of interesting statements about ourselves or about, you know, the most recent news or the context around us. But very often when people have on their mind when they're meeting you is not just,
就是研究当你了解某人时你可能会问的问题类型。你知道，很多时候，我们开始思考问题，是因为我认为我们在试图认识某人时采取的策略往往是给他们留下深刻印象，向他们抛出许多关于我们自己的有趣陈述，或者关于最近的新闻或我们周围的语境。但很多时候，当人们在见你时脑子里想的不仅仅是，
is this person interesting, but are they interested in me? Right. Are they demonstrating that they care about what I'm saying, that they want to hear more? And so we started looking at the questions people ask when they first meet each other. This is both some sort of friendly settings, but we even actually looked at a a data set of speed dates that was collected by some researchers at Stanford, very high stakes first impression setting. And what we saw is that even though people ask a lot of questions, there's only some types of questions that really help build rapport in those initial
这个人有趣吗？而是，他们对我感兴趣吗？对吧？他们是否在表明他们在乎我说的话，他们想听更多？所以我们开始研究人们在初次见面时问的问题。这既有某种友好的环境，但我们甚至还研究了由斯坦福大学的一些研究人员收集的快速约会的数据集，这是一个风险很高的第一印象环境。我们看到的是，尽管人们问了很多问题，但只有某些类型的问题真正有助于在那些初始互动中建立融洽关系
interactions. And specifically, those are follow-up questions. So questions that appreciate what a person said and then dig deeper to help them build more. It's nice because it demonstrates is listening, right? So by asking a follow-up question, I'm asking a question that I only could have asked if I had been listening to what you just said, right? So it's proof, right? I can sit here and nod and make eye contact and give you little back channels while I'm waiting for my turn to say something, right? Now, that's not real proof of grounded listening, but if I can ask questions that show that I'm following the story, that I'm dying to know what's coming next, that that's the really great way to get people to like you more because they feel like you're interested in them.
。具体来说，这些是跟进问题。也就是欣赏一个人说的话然后更深入地挖掘以帮助他们构建更多内容的问题。这很好，因为它表明了倾听，对吧？所以通过问一个跟进问题，我问了一个只有在我一直在听你刚才说的话时才能问出的问题，对吧？所以这是证据，对吧？我可以坐在那儿点头、进行眼神交流，并在等待轮到我说话时给你一些小的反馈，对吧？不，那不是接地气的倾听的真正证据，但如果我能问出表明我一直在跟着故事走、我渴望知道接下来会发生什么的问题，那是让人们更喜欢你的绝佳方式，因为他们觉得你对他们感兴趣。
It's also nice because it keeps the conversation going. It just gives them one more thing to say on a topic that they've already sort of revealed a preference for talking about. And so I try and get in the habit of asking as many follow-up questions as I can. And I think you'd be surprised when you meet somebody, especially if they're a little nervous, if they're worried about how they're coming across. You know, you could ask a lot of follow-up questions before they ask you a question in return. And so you'll learn a lot, but then also they'll also get the side benefit of having them like you more. It's worth mentioning because I think Mike's points are so smart and so great that like if you just ask follow-up questions, people love to answer questions about themselves, right?
这也很好，因为它能让对话继续下去。这只是在一个他们已经表现出对话偏好的主题上，再多给他们一句话可说。因此，我尽量养成尽可能多问跟进问题的习惯。而且我想你会惊讶地发现，当你遇到某人时，特别是如果他们有点紧张、如果他们担心自己给别人留下的印象时。你知道，在你回问他们问题之前，你可以问很多跟进问题。所以你会学到很多东西，同时他们也会获得让你更喜欢他们的额外好处。值得一提的是，因为我认为迈克观点非常聪明且极好，如果你只是问跟进问题，人们很喜欢回答关于他们自己的问题，对吧？
Nobody ever says, you know, you're just too interested in me. But one of the things that I've carried into sort of new encounters is some work from Nicholas Epley. there's actually a whole chapter about Nick Epley in my book. And Mike obviously worked with him for a long time. And one of the things Nick said to me was he said, his goal is to ask a deep question as quickly as possible. And a deep question is basically something that asks someone else to talk about their values or their beliefs or their experiences, to expose a little bit of who they are. And when Nick told me this, I was like, deep question, that sounds really hard to do, like, you know, off the bat. That sounds very intimate.
从来没有人会说，你知道的，你对我也太感兴趣了。但我带入到某种新遭遇中的事情之一是尼古拉斯·埃普利（Nicholas Epley）的一些工作。我的书里实际上有一整章是关于尼克·埃普利的。显然，迈克和他共事了很长时间。尼克对我说的一件事是，他的目标是尽快问出一个深度问题。而深度问题基本上是要求另一个人谈论他们的价值观、信仰或经历，稍微暴露一点他们是谁。当尼克告诉我这个时，我想：深度问题，这听起来很难做到，就像，你知道的，一上来就问。这听起来非常亲密。
And Nick was like, no, no, it's actually just about like, you know, if you ask someone like, where do you work? And your next question is, do you love that job? Or did you always want to do that from when you were a kid? If instead of asking someone where they live, you say, you know, what's the best thing about your neighborhood? Or instead of asking them where they went to high school, what did you learn most in high school? Those are deep questions. They don't seem overly intimate or personal. but they're inviting the other person to talk about their experiences or their values or their beliefs.
而尼克的反应是：不，不，这实际上只是关于，你知道的，如果你问某人“你在哪里工作？”，你的下一个问题是“你热爱那份工作吗？还是你从小就一直想做那个？”如果不是问别人住在哪里，而是说，你知道的，“你社区最好的地方是什么？”或者不是问他们去了哪所高中，“你在高中学到了最多的是什么？”这些都是深度问题。它们看起来并不过于亲密或私人。但它们是在邀请另一个人谈论他们的经历、价值观或信仰。
And in doing so, they become a little bit vulnerable. They expose themselves. And if you reciprocate that vulnerability, if you show them that you are listening and you ask follow-up questions, as Mike pointed out, if you share a little bit about yourself, it's almost impossible not to feel close to that person. So you're mentioning that certain kinds of questions that work better than others to draw people out and to build that. rapport. I imagine that you're familiar with the work of Arthur Arons, who was on this podcast some time ago, and he developed a series of questions that were intended to basically help people fall in love and stay in love. Have you looked at those questions and why do they work the way that he says they work? Oh, yeah. Actually, that chapter about Nick Epley is also the
通过这样做，他们变得有点脆弱。他们暴露了自己。如果你对这种脆弱做出回应，如果你向他们展示你在倾听并问跟进问题，正如迈克所指出的，如果你分享一点关于你自己的事，几乎不可能不对那个人感到亲近。所以你提到某种特定类型的问题比其他问题更能引出人们并建立这种融洽关系。我想你对阿瑟·阿伦斯（Arthur Arons）的工作很熟悉，他前段时间上过这个播客，他开发了一系列旨在基本上帮助人们坠入爱河并保持爱河的问题。你研究过这些问题吗？为什么它们会像他说的那样发挥作用？哦，是的。实际上，关于尼克·埃普利的那一章也是
story of the Fast Friends Protocol and the 36 questions. And Arthur and his wife, they developed that together. And what's really interesting is I talked to a bunch of the grad students who worked with them on developing that. And we think of these 36 questions as like being set in stone, right? But the origin of those questions is actually like almost by happenstance. There was, what they would do, there was this game that was really popular in the 1980s among like college students and stoners named the ungame. Some of you might be familiar with this. And it's basically a bunch of random questions. So they would take these questions and they would, they would experiment with them in, in the, in the fast friends protocol. And they would go to bars and they would just dream up,
关于快速朋友协议（Fast Friends Protocol）和36个问题的故事。阿瑟和他的妻子是一起开发这个的。非常有趣的是，我采访了一群和他们一起开发这个的研究生。我们认为这36个问题是一成不变的，对吧？但这些问题的起源实际上几乎是偶然的。在20世纪80年代的大学生和瘾君子中，有一个非常受欢迎的游戏叫“不游戏”（The ungame）。你们中的一些人可能对这个很熟悉。它基本上是一堆随机的问题。所以他们会把这些问题拿来，并在快速朋友协议中进行实验。他们会去酒吧然后凭空想出
dream up questions. And for anyone who's not a familiar, what the experiment was that the errands conducted was they would bring strangers together. They would give them a list of questions to ask each other, one at a time, and answer. And then people would leave. And these were strangers. And then seven weeks later, they would look to see if anyone who had participated in this had tracked down their partner to try and just have a beer with them. And they found that over 50% of the people who had done these questions, and this is pre-internet, right? They had to like work hard to track down these folks. Over 50% of the people went and found their partner and sort of made, because they felt such a connection with them after asking and answering these questions.
一些问题。对于任何不熟悉的人来说，阿伦斯进行的实验是：他们把陌生人聚集在一起，给他们一份问题清单，让他们逐个提问并回答。然后人们离开。这些人都是陌生人。七周后，他们会查看是否有参与过的人追踪过他们的搭档，只是想和他们喝杯啤酒。他们发现，超过50%做过这些问题的人（这是在互联网之前，对吧？他们必须像这样努力追踪这些人）超过50%的人去找到了他们的搭档并建立某种联系，因为在问答这些问题之后，他们对彼此感到了如此强烈的连结。
And it became known as a Fast Friends Protocol. I'm sure everyone listening has heard of this, has probably used it. But the reason it works, and my Mike, I'd love to hear your thoughts on whether you think this is right. The reason why Arthur told me it works is because of this reciprocal vulnerability. Because I ask you a question that asks you to be a little bit vulnerable. You answer it. And then I respond by answering that same question myself. And that escalating vulnerability, that reciprocation, it just makes us feel close to each other, even if we have nothing in common. We feel close. Yeah, the reciprocal self-disclosure is a really powerful part of that paradigm. I think a little bit is what Nick was talking about, too, in the sense that you sort of ease into the topics that are surprisingly deep. It's an interesting paradigm, too, right? There's a lot of sort of quietly staring into each other eyes. And there's a bit of a structure that kind of gives you the permission to be vulnerable that might be a little trickier in a natural setting, right?
这被称为快速朋友协议。我确信每个收听的人都听说过这个，可能也使用过。但它起作用的原因是——迈克，我很想听听你对这是否正确的想法。阿瑟告诉我它起作用的原因是因为这种相互的脆弱。因为我问你一个要求你表现出一点脆弱的问题。你回答了。然后我通过自己回答同一个问题来回应。这种不断升级的脆弱、这种互惠，让我们感觉彼此亲近，即使我们没有任何共同点。我们感到亲近。是的，相互的自我披露是这种范式中一个非常强大的部分。我认为这有点像尼克刚才谈到的，也就是说，你有点不知不觉地进入那些出人意料的深度话题。这也是一个有趣的范式，对吧？有很多安静地互视对方眼睛的场景。而且有一种结构在某种程度上赋予了你展现脆弱的许可，这在自然环境中可能会棘手一些，对吧？
Like it's a wonder why we don't feel as comfortable sharing our vulnerabilities with people without having an experimenter poking us in the shoulder with a conductor's wand. But I think we all have something to learn from that study for sure. And I think Mike raises a really good point here, which is the structure is really important. Because some of the questions are things like, when's the last time you cried in front of another person? or there's some question about people's mothers, right? Which is not an overwhelmingly positive question. And I think if you're on a first date at a bar and you turn to someone and you say, you know, tell me, when's the last time you cried in front of another person?
就像人们常常好奇，为什么如果没有一个实验者用指挥棒戳我们的肩膀，我们在没有这种外力的情况下，感觉跟别人分享脆弱就没那么自如。但我们肯定都能从那个研究中学到一些东西。而且我认为迈克在这里提出了一个非常好的观点，那就是结构非常重要。因为有些问题比如：你上一次在另一个人面前哭是什么时候？或者有一些关于人们母亲的问题，对吧？这并不是一个压倒性的积极问题。我想如果你在酒吧第一次约会，你转过身对某人说：“你知道，告诉我，你上一次在另一个人面前哭是什么时候？”
Probably that person is not going to take you out on a second date or go on a second day with you, right? Like some of these questions, but it feels fine when we're in a laboratory. But I think the point there is that, as Mike mentions, and I think that plays off of a lot of his research, is that is that we can kind of create structures within our conversations, right? Sometimes announcing our goal at the beginning of a conversation is creating a structure or just saying like, you know, I wanted to get together for drinks with you because I just wanted to get to know you better. Like, tell me about who you are. Oftentimes what we're doing is we're creating structures that make certain kind of statements easier to accomplish, a question. And then a follow-up question
这个人可能不会带你去进行第二次约会，或者跟你进行第二次聚会，对吧？就像其中一些问题一样，但我们在实验室里时感觉很好。但我觉得这里的重点在于，正如迈克所提到的，我认为这也呼应了他的很多研究，那就是我们可以在对话中建立某种结构，对吧？有时在对话开始时宣布我们的目标就是在建立一种结构，或者只是说，你知道的，我想和你一起喝一杯，因为我只是想更好地了解你。比如，跟我讲讲你是个什么样的人。通常我们在做的是，我们正在建立一些结构，使某些类型的陈述更容易实现，比如一个问题。然后是一个后续问题
is often a structuring mechanism. And the more that we sort of think about that, or at least lean into it because it's an instinct for almost all of us, the more I think we make it easier for ourselves and others to respond. Related to that, though, let me ask you if you are about to embark on a difficult conversation and you let somebody know, I'm talking to you, I need to talk to you right now because I'm really angry,
通常是一种结构机制。我们对这一点思考得越多，或者至少去顺应它——因为这几乎是我们所有人的本能，我觉得我们就会越容易让彼此做出回应。不过，与此相关的是，让我问你，如果你即将开始一场艰难的对话，并且你让某人知道，“我正在跟你说话，我现在必须跟你谈谈，因为我真的很生气”，
does that set everything off on a bad path? because now the other person gets defensive. So what should you do as the angry person? What should you do as the person who is maybe the recipient of the anger to keep it from devolving into just a mess? I'm trying to think if it's a harder conversation if one person is angry or if both people are angry. They both pose their own difficulties. I don't know that talking at the peak of your anger is always the best idea. But certainly there's a lot of difficult conversations we have that are all around some kind of disagreement, right? Whether it's a different disagreement about beliefs or values or preferences,
这是否会让一切都走向糟糕的方向？因为现在对方会产生防御心理。那么作为一个正在生气的人，你应该怎么做？作为可能是愤怒接收者的人，你应该怎么做，才能防止事情演变成一团糟？我在想要是一方生气，或者双方都生气，哪种对话会更难。这两种情况都有各自的难处。我不知道在情绪最激动的时候说话是不是总是个好主意。但可以肯定的是，我们经历的许多艰难对话都围绕着某种分歧，对吧？无论是对信仰、价值观还是偏好的不同分歧，
we're constantly engaging with people we disagree with, right? In any group of folks, right, whether we're at work, whether we're managing a household or getting along with our neighbors, right? We're sort of intimately tied with folks who would just by, it was impossible for us to agree with them 100% of the time. So we need to be able to build trust in spite of that disagreement. And I think a tricky thing in a lot of these situations is I think it comes back to goals. So often when we talk to people we disagree with, we're so focused on persuasion, right?
我们不断地与和我们意见不合的人打交道，对吧？在任何群体中，无论是我们在工作、管理家庭还是与邻居相处，对吧？我们与那些哪怕仅凭概率也不可能百分之百与我们意见一致的人紧密相连。因此，尽管存在这种分歧，我们仍需要建立信任。我认为在许多这类情况下，一个棘手的问题在于，它又归结为了目标。通常，当我们与意见不合的人交谈时，我们太专注于说服了，对吧？
Like, this person is wrong. They have a bad view of the world. So I just need to correct their view of the world and then everything will be good again. But like, you know, the hit rate on persuasion attempts these days is vanishingly small, right? If anything, the two people end up further away than they started, right? But the thing is, if you disagree with somebody about something and you talked about it and you haven't come to a resolution, you know, in our negotiations class, we teach that means one of three things, right? Either you're wrong or the other person is wrong or both of you are wrong. And so there's a very different set of conversational skills that come into play when we disagree with people, right?
比如，这个人错了。他们对世界的看法是不对的。所以我只需要纠正他们对世界的看法，一切就又都好了。但是，你知道，如今说服尝试的成功率低得惊人，对吧？如果说有什么不同的话，那就是两个人最终的立场比开始时离得更远了，对吧？但问题是，如果你在某事上与某人意见不合，并且你们谈过了却没有达成共识，你知道，在我们的谈判课上，我们教导说这意味着三种情况之一，对吧？要么你错了，要么另一个人错了，或者你们两个都错了。因此，当我们与他人意见不合时，会涉及一套非常不同的对话技巧，对吧？
If we focus on trust building and understanding, right, that's something that both people can achieve together, right? Even if I don't convince you that your opinion on, you know, Middle East politics or climate change or, you know, where we should go on vacation next holiday, even if I can't win you over, I can still give you the gift of listening to what you have to say. I can express some intellectual humility myself by hedging statements by using tools to identify subjective language, right? So I believe this. I think that, you know, I understand where you're coming from. I can seek points of agreement, right, rather than focusing on the narrow things where we disagree. So there's a lot of errors of omission that we make when we disagree with people, right? Things we should say more of. And there's also errors of commission, right? We contradict people too much. We minimize their beliefs by using words like just and only. We try and explain things to them as if, you know, we're a teacher talking to a student rather than two people of equal. status, trying to manage a disagreement between one another. And so, you know, my colleagues and I have worked a lot on this sort of suite of conversational tools. We like to call conversational receptiveness, which is active engagement with people you disagree with.
如果我们专注于建立信任和理解，对吧，那是双方可以共同实现的目标，对吧？即使我无法让你相信你对中东政治、气候变化或者我们下次假期该去哪里度假的观点，即使我无法赢得你的认同，我仍然可以给予你倾听你所说之话的礼物。我自己也可以表达一些知识上的谦逊，比如在陈述中使用缓和语调，使用能够识别主观语言的工具，对吧？所以我相信这一点。我认为，你知道的，我理解你的立场。我可以寻找双方意见一致的点，而不是把注意力放在我们意见不合的狭隘事情上。因此，当我们与他人意见不合时，我们会犯下许多遗漏错误，对吧？即我们应该多说的话。同时也会犯下作为错误，对吧？我们太多地反驳别人。我们用“仅仅”和“唯一”等词来贬低他们的信念。我们试图向他们解释事情，就好像我们是一个老师在和一个学生说话，而不是两个地位平等、试图处理彼此分歧的人。所以，你知道，我的同事和我在这类对话工具上做了很多工作。我们喜欢称之为“对话接受度”，也就是与那些你意见不合的人进行积极互动。
And what's interesting is that we show that this really builds trust in a lot of settings. So we've looked at this in, you know, telemedicine, we've looked at this in online classes, We've looked at discussions among Wikipedia editors and local government officials, all kinds of folks who are intimately engaged with folks they disagree with as part of a productive enterprise. And in all these cases, people who use these most more receptive language, which honestly doesn't sound much different from the sort of rule of thumb you kind of get from the literature on couples counseling in the 1960s. We build trust in these relationships, the same way these couples do when they're having arguments. But what's interesting is that the persuasion actually comes as a result of that trust. So rather than trading off persuasion against trust, right? We express a little humility and we think maybe we're giving into the other side.
有趣的是，我们发现这确实在很多场景下建立起了信任。我们研究过远程医疗领域的这种情况，在线课程中的这种情况，维基百科编辑和地方政府官员之间的讨论，以及所有那些在生产性事业中与意见不合的人密切互动的各类人群。在所有这些情况下，使用这种更具接受度语言的人——老实说，这听起来与20世纪60年代伴侣咨询文献中的经验法则没有太大区别——我们在这些关系中建立信任，就像这些伴侣在争吵时所做的那样。但有趣的是，说服实际上是这种信任的结果。因此，我们并没有用说服来换取信任，对吧？我们表现出一点谦逊，我们觉得也许我们在向对方妥协。
In fact, that makes us more trustworthy and thus more persuasive. A colleague of mine has a great analogy of trying to enter a castle, like a medieval castle with a giant moat and a drawbridge. right, to get in to see the king, you have to get them to lower the drawbridge, right? They don't lower the drawbridge, you're not getting in. So there's no point to begin with. And so in our research, we've shown that those extra tools, right, making really, really sure that the other person understands that you've listened to them before you launch into your statement about your side. I think that's a really good point. Yeah.
事实上，这使我们更值得信赖，从而更有说服力。我的一个同事有一个很好的类比，关于试图进入一座城堡，比如一座带有巨大护城河和吊桥的中世纪城堡，对吧？要想进去见国王，你得让他们放下吊桥，对吧？他们如果不放下吊桥，你就进不去。所以一开始就没有意义。因此，在我们的研究中，我们发现那些额外的工具，对吧，在开始陈述你这一方的观点之前，千方百计确保对方明白你已经听取了他们的意见。我认为这是一个非常好的观点。是的。
And to build on that, you know, and the work that Mike has done with collaborators, including Allison Woodbrook, at HBS, you know, one of the things that comes across so strongly in that literature and other experiments is that oftentimes we think about conversation as starting when I open my mouth. But in many ways, as we had discussed before, it's the work we do before we open our mouth. And equally importantly, the work we do after someone else has spoken to show them that we've listened to them. And one of my favorite ways of thinking about this is this technique called looping for understanding that many people listening who teach negotiations probably know, which is it's very, very simple.
在此基础上，你知道的，迈克和包括哈佛商学院的艾莉森·伍德布鲁克在内的合作者所做的工作，你知道，在这些文献和其他实验中非常鲜明地体现出来的一点是，通常我们认为对话是从我开口说话时开始的。但在很多方面，正如我们之前讨论过的，它是我们在开口说话之前所做的工作。同样重要的是，在别人说完话之后，我们所做的工作，向他们展示我们已经听取了他们的意见。我最喜欢的思考方式之一就是这种被称为“循环理解”的技术，许多听过谈判课的听众可能都知道，它是非常非常简单的。
When you're in a conversation, particularly around conflict, and someone has said something, the best way to disarm the conversation, to prove to them that you are listening is you ask them a question about what they just said. You repeat back in your own words what you heard them say. and then you ask them if you got it right. And of course, we've all learned this when we were like in fourth grade, right? Like this is listening 101. And yet, and yet if you think about the last conversation all of us had when we were in conflict with someone, we probably didn't do a lot of looping for understanding.
当你处于对话中，特别是在围绕冲突的对话中，当某人说了一些话时，解除对话武装、向他们证明你在倾听的最好方法，就是向他们提出一个关于他们刚刚所说内容的问题。用你自己的话复述你听到他们所说的话，然后问他们你是否理解正确。当然，我们在大概四年级的时候就都学过这个，对吧？这就像倾听入门101。然而，然而，如果你想想我们所有人最近一次与某人发生冲突的对话，我们可能并没有做太多的循环理解。
But if you're in that situation and someone comes up and they say, what I heard, like, let me ask you one thing about your opinion. What I heard you say is this. And they genuinely try and in their own words, restate what you're saying. restate what you're what you're the argument you're trying to make and then say and before we proceed can I just ask you did I get that right am I understanding you at that point it's pretty hard to see the other person as the enemy because they have shown you they have proved to you that they want to understand you that doesn't mean they agree with you it doesn't mean they expect you to agree with them but at least you know you're being heard and once you have that trust that conversational receptiveness
但如果你处于那种情况下，有人走过来对你说：“我听到的，比如，让我问你一个关于你意见的问题。我听到你说的是这个。”然后他们真诚地尝试用自己的话重新陈述你所说的话，重新陈述你试图提出的论点，然后说：“在我们继续之前，我能问一下我理解对了吗？我是这样理解你的吗？”在那个时候，你很难把对方视为敌人，因为他们已经向你展示、向你证明了他们想要理解你。这并不意味着他们同意你的观点，也不意味着他们期望你同意他们的观点，但至少你知道自己被倾听了。一旦你有了这种信任，这种对话接受度，
then it's much more likely that you're going to find places where you do agree with each other alongside the places where you don't. And that sounds like a tactic that people could employ if they're trying to become better conversationalists. Are there other tips that either of you might offer to our listeners who maybe recognize or maybe they don't recognize that they're bad conversationalists, but would still like to be good? We talked a little bit about follow-up questions already, and I think that's a really generative and lasting approach.
那么你们就更有可能在意见不合的地方之外，找到彼此意见一致的地方。这听起来像是一个人们如果想成为更好的对话者可以采用的策略。你们两位还能向我们的听众提供其他什么建议吗？他们可能意识到，也可能没有意识到自己是不擅长对话的人，但仍然想成为好对话者？我们之前已经讨论过一些后续问题，我认为这是一种非常富有成效且持久的方法。
I will say that we have some other research on questions that might not go as well, which are, there's a technique that, I don't know if any of you ever talk to my dad, you might know, we call it boomer asking. And the idea is that if you want to talk about a topic, you ask somebody else about it first so that you can then jump in. in and give your opinion. It has an intuitive appeal, right? Like, I really, really want to tell this person about my great vacation that I went on last weekend. But I should probably include them and ask them about what their vacation was before I launched into my things, right?
我要说的是，我们还有关于其他可能进展得不太顺利的问题的研究，有一种技术，我不知道你们有没有人跟我的爸爸交谈过，你们可能会知道，我们称之为“婴儿潮一代式提问”。这个想法是，如果你想谈论一个话题，你先问别人关于这个话题的问题，这样你就可以随后插话并发表你的意见。这有一种直观的吸引力，对吧？比如，我真的很想跟这个人讲讲我上周末去度过的美好假期。但在我滔滔不绝讲我自己的事情之前，我可能应该把他们纳入进来，问问他们的假期是怎么过的，对吧？
It seems like it's being responsive, but people catch on to this pretty quickly, right? They can see the insincerity if we haven't done a lot of work to actually listen to what they have to say. And so we actually find that when you're when you want to talk about something great, it's better to just brag than to do the boomer ask and ask before bragging. It's also true for complaining too, right? So if you had a miserable day yesterday, it's probably just better to go in and talk about that and turn this into an emotional conversation rather than pretend you cared about what the other person did yesterday. So even complaining is better if it's explicit rather than channel through the boomer ask.
这看起来像是在做出回应，但人们很快就会识破这一点，对吧？如果我们没有做很多工作去真正倾听他们要说的话，他们就能看出其中的不真诚。所以我们实际上发现，当你想要谈论一件很棒的事情时，直接吹嘘其实比使用婴儿潮一代式提问、在吹嘘之前先假装询问要好。抱怨也是如此，对吧？所以如果你昨天度过了悲惨的一天，可能最好直接切入并谈论这件事，把它变成一场情感对话，而不是假装你关心别人昨天做了什么。因此，即使是抱怨，如果是明确表达出来的，也比通过婴儿潮一代式提问拐弯抹角要好。
And so there's a lot of very tricky rules. It's hard to have one particular piece of advice for all conversations, depending on what you want, depending what the other person has in mind when you get to know them. There could be all kinds of tools. Charles, what comes in mind for you? Yeah. So my book Super Communicators is basically, it's a bunch of stories about people who, interesting communication challenges.
所以这里面有很多非常棘手的规则。很难有一条特定的建议适用于所有的对话，这取决于你想要什么，取决于当你去了解对方时对方心里在想什么。可能会有各种各样的工具。查尔斯，你脑子里浮现出什么？是的。所以我的书《超级沟通者》基本上是，它是一群人的故事，他们面临着有趣的沟通挑战。
but then a lot of tips about how we actually, how we learn these skills, right? How we use them. And some, in addition to what Mike mentioned, I think some other ones are, for instance, you know,
但随后也有很多关于我们实际上如何学习这些技能的建议，对吧？我们如何使用它们。除了迈克提到的内容之外，我认为还有一些其他的，例如，你知道，
Mike had mentioned that marriage counseling in the 1960s when there was really this revolution in the 60s and 70s. And one of the big ideas that came out of that was a lot of couples have trouble communicating with each other when they're trying to control each other. And sometimes we don't understand
迈克曾提到20世纪60年代的婚姻咨询，当时在60年代和70年代确实发生了这场革命。其中产生的一个重要观点是，许多伴侣在试图控制彼此的时侯，在沟通上会遇到困难。有时我们并不理解
that we're trying to control each other. we say things like, you know, if we're in a fight, like, I'm going to give this five minutes, or if you say that one more time, I'm going to walk out of this room. And that's an attempt to control the other person. And it tends to be toxic. Online, that often happens, right? Again, without intending to try and control each other, we signal that we want to control each other by saying, you know, you've analyzed this problem all wrong or I'm not going to sit here
我们在试图控制彼此。我们说一些这样的话，比如，如果我们正在吵架，“我要给这五分钟时间”，或者“如果你再多说一次，我就要离开这个房间”。这是对另一个人的控制尝试。而且它往往是有毒的。在网上，这种情况经常发生，对吧？同样，在没有意图试图控制彼此的情况下，我们通过说“你对这个问题的分析完全错误”或者“我不会坐在这里听这些”来发出我们想要控制彼此的信号。
and listen to that. And I think that the more we think about giving up control in a conversation, letting it flow naturally, the better that conversation is likely going to be. Another tip that we can use, and we haven't really talked about non-linguistic communication, right? When we send messages with our bodies or with our sighs or our laughs, simply drawing our attention to those signals can really help a conversation. And in fact, there's a story in the book about in the 1980s, NASA had this one psychologist who was trying to figure out how to recruit more astronauts that had emotional intelligence. And the problem for him is that astronaut candidates, particularly elite astronaut candidates, they're really good at answering questions, right? They practice for every question. And they're really good at faking emotional intelligence because they know that they're supposed to exhibit it.
我认为，我们在对话中越是考虑放弃控制，让它自然流淌，那场对话往往就会越好。我们可以使用的另一个技巧，我们还没有真正讨论过非语言沟通，对吧？当我们用身体、叹气或笑声发送信息时，简单地将我们的注意力吸引到这些信号上，就能极大地帮助对话。事实上，书中有一个故事：在20世纪80年代，美国宇航局有一位心理学家，他试图找出如何招募更多具备情商的宇航员。对他来说，问题在于宇航员候选人，尤其是精英宇航员候选人，他们非常擅长回答问题，对吧？他们为每一个问题都做过练习。而且他们非常擅长伪装情商，因为他们知道自己应该表现出情商。
And so this guy was trying to figure out, how do I like, how do I actually figure out who like can connect with other people and who can't? Because if I was, if we're sending them into space for six months at a time, that connecting ability is really important. And what he discovered by listening to old recordings of interviews is that if he paid attention to how the candidates laughed, it gave him a clue as to their emotional IQ. In particular, he started going into interviews and he would laugh very boisterously. And he would pay attention to whether the astronaut can't. would laugh back at the basic same energy and same mood level. And then he would laugh quietly and see how the astronaut responded to that. And it wasn't just laughter.
所以这家伙试图弄清楚，我怎么才能——我到底该如何弄清楚谁能与其他人建立联系，谁不能呢？因为如果我们要把他们送进太空，每次待上六个月，这种建立联系的能力就非常重要。通过听旧的采访录音，他发现如果他注意候选人是如何笑的，就能提供关于他们情商的线索。特别是，他开始进入面试环节，并会非常喧闹地大笑。他会注意宇航员候选人是否会以基本相同的精力和相同的心情水平回报以笑声。然后他会安静地笑，看看宇航员是如何反应的。而且不仅仅是笑声。
He would also, he would mention that he had a sister who passed away, which was actually not true. He never had a sister. But he would mention this in these interviews to see whether the candidate would try and comfort him and ask questions, whether they would share about a loss from their own life. It put differently, one of the things that he was doing was he was just training himself to pay attention to the non-linguistic clues that we give each other. And sometimes it's just as simple as that, just reminding ourselves like,
他还提到，他有一个妹妹去世了，这其实不是真的。他从来没有过妹妹。但他会在这些面试中提到这一点，以观察候选人是否会试图安慰他并提出问题，是否会分享他们自己生活中的损失。换句话说，他正在做的事情之一就是训练自己去注意我们彼此发出的非语言线索。有时就是这么简单，只是提醒自己，
pay attention to where the person's eyes are, pay attention to whether they seem to be laughing with me or not. These are just little things, little ways to remind ourselves, much like looping for understanding, right? They're just little mnemonics almost to remind us what we already know about communication. And it can feel overwhelming. But it doesn't have to be. they're all little things that if we just become more, more habitualized around doing them,
注意那个人的眼睛在哪里，注意他们似乎是否在和我一起笑。这些都只是小事情，是提醒我们自己的小方法，很像循环理解，对吧？它们几乎只是小助记符，用来提醒我们已经了解的关于沟通的知识。这可能会让人感到压倒性的压力。但其实不必如此。这些都是小事情，如果我们只是对它们更加习惯化，
suddenly we start having much better conversations. Yeah, Charles, that's such a fascinating story. And it hits on, I think, another really foundational principle of social interaction, which is mimicry, right? A really good predictor of how someone's going to behave is how they're being treated. We're just hopelessly entrained to one another's behavior, right? And you see mimicry in so many different dimensions of human interaction, right? One person looks at something.
突然之间，我们开始进行好得多的对话。是的，查尔斯，这是一个非常迷人的故事。我认为它触及了社会互动的另一个非常基础的原则，那就是模仿，对吧？一个人将如何表现的一个非常好的预测指标就是他们是如何被对待的。我们只是无可救药地被卷入彼此的行为中，对吧？你在人类互动的许多不同维度中都能看到模仿，对吧？一个人看着某样东西。
We look at the same thing. We mimic each other in body posture. We mimic each other in gestures and facial expressions and motion and tone of voice. And certainly in the words we use too. And that can be a really powerful tool, right? That is unconscious cues in mimicry that signal that someone is on the same wavelength as us, that there's a bit of a shared reality, right? That we're enjoying the same things about the situation or, you know,
我们也看着同样的东西。我们在身体姿势上互相模仿。我们在手势、面部表情、动作和语调上互相模仿。当然，在我们使用的词语上也是如此。这可以是一个非常强大的工具，对吧？那是模仿中的无意识线索，它表明某人和我们处于同一频段，存在某种共享的现实，对吧？我们在享受情况中的相同事物，或者，
miscerating about the same things about the situation, right? That we're seeing things in the same way. Yeah. But I think this is a powerful tool. You know, I think in our work on disagreement, we're focusing a lot on the role of mimicry. And I think, you know, we're always, we're very often focused on how we can get other people to treat us with more respect, right? How we can encourage others to demonstrate receptiveness to us.
在情况中对相同的事情发牢骚，对吧？我们以同样的方式看待事物。是的。但我认为这是一个强大的工具。你知道，我认为在我们关于分歧的研究中，我们非常关注模仿的作用。并且我认为，你知道，我们总是，我们非常经常地关注我们如何能让别人用更多的尊重来对待我们，对吧？我们如何能鼓励他人向我们表现出接受度。
And we found that one of the most powerful ways to encourage receptiveness in others is to be receptive yourself. Yeah. That it improves other people's view of us and also all of our counterparts. And we can actually create these microcultures of respect and trust simply by making that choice ourselves. It's not sort of a one-to-one relationship, but the more we can express it ourselves, the more that people sort of unconsciously pick up on that tone and will reflect it back to us.
我们发现，鼓励他人接受度的最强大方法之一，就是你自己要具有接受度。是的。这改善了其他人对我们的看法，也改善了我们所有对话者的看法。而且我们实际上可以通过自己做出这种选择，来创建这些尊重和信任的微观文化。这并不是一种一一对应的关系，但我们自己表达得越多，人们就会在某种程度上无意识地捕捉到那种语调，并会把它反射给我们。
And so even if it feels a little unnatural at first, once that cycle of respect starts revving up, it starts to feel real and hopefully can create a little more of a safe space that maybe didn't feel possible when you get started. Yeah, I think that's a really good point. And it kind of raises this thing that we haven't talked about yet, but which, of course, underlies all of this, which is the reason why mimicry is so important and so powerful is because in many ways, mimicry is the point of communication, right? We haven't talked about neural entrainment and the work from Ari Hassan and Taliawee
所以，即使一开始感觉有点不自然，一旦尊重循环开始启动，它就开始感觉真实，并希望能创造出更多起初开始时可能觉得不可能的安全空间。是的，我认为这是一个非常好的观点。它引出了我们尚未讨论的一点，但当然，这是这一切的基础，那就是模仿之所以如此重要、如此强大，是因为在许多方面，模仿就是沟通的目的，对吧？我们还没有讨论阿里·哈桑（Ari Hassan）和塔利亚·威（Taliawi）关于神经同步（neural entrainment）的研究，
looking at how our bodies become similar when we're in a when we're in conversation with each other. Our eyes sometimes start dilating at the same rate. We start breathing in similar ways. But most importantly, our brains become more similar. And that's kind of the goal of communication, right? Is if I'm feeling a certain emotion and I, through my words, can inspire you to feel that same emotion, then we have some level of understanding. We're communing with each other. And this mimicry is part of communication. It's in some ways the point of communication is for us to align our thoughts and our emotions and our beliefs at least enough to understand what each other is saying and to transmit an idea or a feeling. And I think that's really, really powerful.
他们研究了当我们彼此对话时，我们的身体是如何变得相似的。我们的眼睛有时开始以相同的速率放大。我们开始以类似的方式呼吸。但最重要的是，我们的大脑变得更加相似。这就是沟通的目标，对吧？如果我正在感受到某种情绪，并且我通过我的语言能够激发你感受到同样的情绪，那么我们就达到了一定程度的理解。我们在彼此交流。这种模仿是沟通的一部分。在某些方面，沟通的目的是让我们对齐思想、情感和信念，至少达到足以理解彼此在说什么并传递一个想法或感觉的程度。我认为这真的非常非常强大。
And if we're focused on that as a goal, then mimicry doesn't become sort of this slavish devotion to someone else's to imitating someone else. It rather becomes the path to actually achieving communion. So I want to ask one question to wrap up here, and I'll ask you both. Has your work in this area changed the way that you talk with people and what lessons have you put into practice in your own life? And for you, Charles, did you become a better manager? I did. I did. And actually, I mean, I will say it has revolutionized how I communicate.
如果我们以此为目标，那么模仿就不会变成对别人的盲目顺从，不会变成对别人的模仿。相反，它成了真正实现交流的途径。所以我想问最后一个问题来收尾，我要问你们两个。在这个领域的开创性工作是否改变了你与人交谈的方式，你在自己的生活中实践了哪些经验？对于你，查尔斯，你成为了一名更好的管理者吗？我是。我是。实际上，我的意思是，我要说这彻底改变了我的沟通方式。
I mean, not just with people at work, but also, you know, with my wife, with my kids. I mean, it's just taught me to think so much more deeply about how I'm communicating. And that can sound like a burden, right? Like it makes every conversation kind of this mental struggle. But actually what I found is that it makes communication much easier. Like, I actually get to think less because I know that I should ask a follow-up question. Or I know that I should reciprocate vulnerability when someone is vulnerable with me. You know, one of the first things that like often happens when I'm talking to my wife,
我的意思是，不仅是与工作中的人，还有，你知道的，与我的妻子，与我的孩子们。我的意思是，它教会了我更深入地思考我是如何沟通的。这听起来可能是一个沉重的负担，对吧？就好像让每一次对话都变成这种精神上的挣扎。但实际上我发现，这让沟通变得容易得多。比如，我实际上需要想的更少了，因为我知道我应该问一个后续问题。或者我知道当有人对我展现脆弱时，我应该回报以脆弱。你知道，当我跟我妻子说话时，通常发生的头几件事情之一，
And there's a shorthand we use for this that I think has become popular in schools, which is when we start talking to each other, we say, so do you want me to hear you? Do you want me to help you? Or do you want me to hug you? Right? And this is basically back to the beginning of our conversation. This is asking them what their goal is. Do you want me to solve? Is this a practical conversation? You want me to help you solve it? Or do you want me just to hear your emotions, which is, you know, an emotional listening conversation? Or do you want me to hug you? to sort of a social conversation to show you that we are still together. And simply asking that question has like, and I ask it all the time now. I drive people crazy with it. But like, it's this magical thing that all of a sudden people say like, oh, I want you to hear me. And then I know what my job is and they know what their job is. And things go so much more smoothly. Mike, what about you?
我们对此使用了一种简写，我认为这在学校里已经变得很流行，那就是当我们开始互相交谈时，我们会说：“所以，你是希望我听你倾听？你是希望我帮你想办法？还是你希望我给你一个拥抱？”对吧？这基本上回到了我们对话的开始。这就是询问他们的目标是什么。你是想让我解决吗？这是一个实际的对话吗？你想让我帮你解决它吗？还是你只是想让我倾听你的情绪，也就是，你知道的，一个情感倾听的对话？或者你是想让我给你一个拥抱？这是一种社交对话，向你表明我们仍然在一起。仅仅提出这个问题就好像，我现在一直在问它。我用它把人们弄疯了。但是，这是一个神奇的事情，突然之间人们会说：“哦，我希望你倾听我。”然后我就知道我的工作是什么，他们也知道他们的工作是什么。事情进行得顺畅多了。迈克，你呢？
That's a really good one. I mean, I think it's so funny with science. I do think we're making a lot of progress. but sometimes the more you study a subject, the less you feel like you know about it. And for me, you know, I do a lot of follow-up questions. I do a lot of conversational receptiveness. I think my disagreements are more productive, although you'd have to ask my colleagues in Imperial College about that.
那真的是一个很好的观点。我的意思是，科学真的很有趣。我确实认为我们正在取得很大进展，但有时你对一个主题研究得越多，你就越觉得自己对它知之甚少。对我来说，你知道，我做了很多后续问题。我做了很多对话接受度。我认为我的分歧更具建设性，尽管你得去问我在帝国理工学院的同事。
You know, it's more the deep humility, right? I plan to be surprised and I plan to learn from people because it's just so much more complicated than you can anticipate going forward. I always feel like there's so much more to learn than I could ever get out of one conversation. I've learned a lot with the two of you today, more than planned even. Yeah, me too.
你知道，更多的是深沉的谦逊，对吧？我准备好感到惊讶，我准备好向人们学习，因为这比你向前预期的要复杂得多。我总觉得有太多东西要学，远超过我能从一次对话中获得的。我今天从你们俩身上学到了很多，甚至超过了计划。是的，我也是。
Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today. I think it was a great conversation. Me too. Thanks for having me. Absolutely. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
好吧，我要感谢你们两位今天能来参加。我认为这是一场非常棒的对话。我也是。谢谢邀请我。绝对的，这是一种荣幸。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》以前的节目。
And if you like what you've heard, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔迪安（Chris Condyenne）。谢谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。这一集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。